[Music]
yes I absolutely I love kids
Taylor Lautner gets candid about
becoming a father someday a theme
heavily explored in his new drama run
the tide what are you thinking and I'm
just gonna give him to you no I'm taking
it I know you're not a parent in the
film but essentially in many ways you
are how did you pull those fatherly
instincts out and really channel them on
the screen I'm blessed to have two
amazing parents and then also I have a
younger sister who is my world were
extremely close and I was able to you
know use that relationship I have in my
real life with you know raised
relationship with Oliver and that was
extremely helpful we've been better
parents to Oliver than she ever was I'm
not gonna let her take him from me
does it get you thinking about maybe
having a family yourself someday is that
a goal I you know it's certainly not
ready for it yet but yes I absolutely I
love kids I love family so one day I
very much look forward to that when we
find mrs. right absolutely
here we go I have to give you a
compliment you know what we want as an
audience we want the waterworks but you
know we want a little shirtlessness we
want a little sexy you had it a
beautiful scene with Johanna in this
film what do you do prior to that is
there a conversation you guys have to
kind of minimize the awkwardness there
always is that like checkup conversation
hey you know this is about ready a
little weird but we're in it together
right yeah and then as you're filming it
you're always checking in you're like
hey you okay like make sure not to
anything I'm not posting yeah it's not
as intimate as it seems right you've got
about four phone everywhere forty
middle-aged men watching you do all of
it and it's it's nice my definition of
sexy yes right what everybody wants
right aboard with them know when they're
having this moment
you